shark attacks have been increasingly
been increasing for the last 11 decades
my name is George Burgess I serve as
director of the Florida program for
shark research when we enter the sea
it's a wilderness experience if you're
paranoid about getting bit and obviously
stay outside of the water work on your
suntan drink a cold one on the beach
enjoy the scenery but if you go in the
water you know that there's a there's
going to be some risk and it's our duty
to reduce that risk if we can how do we
do that reduction well first of all we
can go out in groups their safety in
numbers as a reason why fishes are in
school and antelopes are in herds is
because there's the safety there so go
together as a group don't go to come ice
elated because carnivores such as a
shark go after after the lonely person
don't go in the water between dusk and
dawn time periods when sharks are most
active in feeding avoid certain areas
where sharks are likely to be found in
le'ts channels you see sea birds diving
to see fishes jumping if you see humans
fishing off the shoreline that means
there's fish around if there's fish
there's probably sharks so just by doing
those sort of common-sense kind of
things we can reduce our risk if you see
a shark while in the water of course the
first thing to do is to get out if you
can and that seems obvious to to most
people but surfers in particular who a
swim a lot in the water and see sharks
oftentimes don't worry about it because
they've been with them before and then
sometimes they get bit so get out of the
water if you see a shark